why is every pretty girl with a horrible
looking man don't understand
listen i'm not shaming
people for their looks but i am though
you give an ugly guy a chance he thinks
he rules the world
lit i swear to god
because they got a hot girl they can be
horrible
like you're still ugly though
you can't change that maybe that's why
i'm sorry but i simply cannot stay quiet
any longer women you have got to stop
dating ugly men you've got to stop you
are setting feminism back years i am so
sick of walking down the street and
seeing the most beautiful woman i've
ever seen in my life with just some guy
with a solid four
like i understand that you value charity
work but sis go to a soup kitchen enough
is enough
stay away from ugly man i've heard that
before yes yeah i've heard that before
okay what happened doctor no no it's
just it's just girls say that a lot it's
been going on
i remember that one video when she was
talking about no no it's like they get
you give them a chance and then they
think they're all the [ __ ] and
everything and stuff yeah it's something
that's been going on been going around i
mean
i mean
you know what it is i'll tell you guys
what it is
it's not that ugly men treat women worse
or better than attractive dudes it's not
that
is that when a ugly man treats you
better it's more insulting
sorry when an ugly man treats you worse
it's more insulting absolutely do you
like [ __ ] absolutely i gave you you
were changed that's how they think of
him they had and so like you would do
this to me
so then why would i even get with an
ugly dude is this some more is some more
is some more skit
so you know some more she's a
comedian all right some more and she had
i think it was some more and she was
saying
uh
if you got a little dick you better
lower your tone
kind of the same thing because if i got
a big dick i gotta be talking to you any
kind of wig cause it justifies shut the
[ __ ] up what'd you say to me i got a big
dick oh i'm sorry daddy you know what i
mean like is the
is that [ __ ]
it's just a flop but now if i'm a ugly
if i'm a
good looking guy there's another girl
that was like yo if you get dumped by an
ugly guy it hurts more than a pretty god
the same [ __ ] that's like stop
stop dating ugly guys or the same
[ __ ] are gonna turn around and
talk about body positivity and you need
hold up yo
yo that is such a good point hey billy
eyelessness
no no hey
bring that [ __ ] back
bring it back hey billy yeah
knock down big these are billy
billy eyes ain't she the the the big
titty [ __ ] who was saying i wear thick
clothes i don't get sexualized and i
don't be and you out here just talking
about ugly dudes like that yeah they're
the ones
i think i think i think the pot is
calling the petal kettle something like
that whatever
fire [ __ ] you getting fired she has to
go this one has to leave the premises
they're gonna yeah you nailed that [ __ ]
again that's all
[Music]
yeah
they're going to be the ones talking
about body positivity and you need to do
this you need to do that [ __ ] ugly dudes
but yeah if you guys are wondering why
billy eilish is always dressed in
oversized tea like a [ __ ] hood [ __ ]
from the 2000s okay
it's because she got big old titties and
she don't want to be sexualized all the
time and be looked at for her looks or
whatever which is fine which is fine but
you're gonna turn around about ugly
dudes girl
they should recently come on some
lingerie and focus on mad too whatever
it's these things sometimes
that's such a good point bro these
people are
they're gonna be the same ones uh the
same ones oh my days
you wanted to say all my days but oh my
god
did you notice my skin on that video
oh that that skin is glimmering if you
want to have a wonderful skin like mild
it's good because this this video is
brought to you by th gently your skin
care routine is gonna be on point but i
suggest you to take the level one box
yeah you take the level one box and
there's instruction and wonderful
products such as a daily face wash you
need to wash your face
you see me you need to wash it there's
an exfoliating cream the exfoliating or
washable it's just to get in the nooks
and crannies it's good to wash but then
after that you have to scrub because you
have dead skin and stuff like that you
have an am and a pm facial a.m and p.m
who doesn't like a little facial in the
am or the pm you need to moisturize your
skin and on top of that they have one
with a spf 20 you know because of the
sun
but if you click on the link below you
could go right now you click on the link
below and you're going to be able to
save 30
off your first box yeah 30 off your
first box
and they're gonna send you a gift you
got a 30 off a gift what more do you
want a perfect skin they're gonna get
you that too
the difference between a creepy man and
a not creepy guy he's not hot easy yeah
that's the only difference christian
grey
christian grey is one of the one of the
creepiest [ __ ] ever can i ask
anybody when you guys see all these like
super attractive dudes in hollywood all
treating their wives cheating on them
having four different ones like what you
think attractive news would be better of
course not it's just more insulting when
it's an ugly dude because it bruises
your ego a little bit more i could have
done so much better but if you know
anything about dating and dynamics it's
like yeah girls do the whole thing where
they go for hot guys in their young
years and then they go on later in life
and realize they want a bit of security
and safety remember this dude oh the
criminal prison bay remember this dude
oh yeah this this this jeremy meeks yeah
they them them that picture came out and
don't matter what the hell he was in his
old prison fatigue
shout out to him shout out to this guy
this dude got out of jail and was dating
a billionaire's daughter this guy got
out of jail
bring it back he got out of jail after
like
a couple years and was dating
a billionaire's daughter modeling
contract and [ __ ]
i mean he broke up with her too but you
get my honesty don't matter it's
different money doesn't matter it's a
different life
listen
he was blowing out her back said [ __ ]
hey man let me tell you something about
bars because i've been behind them and
i'm about to put them in you you feel me
yo my man was going in like [ __ ] drop
that song i'm gonna see i'm gonna teach
you what i learned yo
she she she she
she ah loser listen akon she's locked up
yo that that [ __ ] is real to get out of
jail and be with a billionaire but again
that's one of those things where where
you're hot like it's a different set of
rules
but i don't mean you get treated better
i just
it's more insulting yeah it hurts more
yeah it hurts more when they drop you it
hurts more when they talk to you it's
actually you yeah you hit it on the on
the head yeah
you hit the nail on the head it really
is just more insulting
you know and that that's the thing and
that's the thing whenever girls get
pissed off
when they get pissed off and they break
off with you what do they say you ugly
anyways
you little dick ass if he's ugly you
dated him stupid one and two if he
cheated on you that means some other
[ __ ] wanted to [ __ ] him too
i don't know how ugly he really is if he
getting all this [ __ ] you feel me
but but it's really because it hurts it
hurts it says more i'm just saying it
says more about you than it says about
him but it is what it is let me just
that's really that let me just say
if you don't understand why really
attractive women are with ugly dudes is
because you don't understand the dynamic
between men and women
women look for different things than men
yep just what it is
women want that sense of security right
they want to be cared for they want to
make sure that the finances are in order
that someone's actually going to be
attentive listen whether you like it or
not attractive dudes are way more likely
to cheat yes i said wonder why because
they got more options because they can
and cheating is generally ferment a
matter of opportunity
so if you want security if you want some
monogamous that has an opportunity to
flourish you're going to get with the
duties generally a little bit less
attractive because the really hot dude
that you're seeing that well guess what
is you ain't the only one in line and
you ain't the only one in the dms
so
that's why women should go for dudes who
are a little bit less good-looking and
you know what it's not that big of a
trade-off because you just want somebody
to care and nurture yourself well that's
why some women but a lot of women are
everyone every woman really wants like a
ten and a nine like it's like all these
women ranging from four
that's what they want you know i mean
what they want ranging from fours to
tens all want the
nine to tens i mean everybody wants an
attractive partner sure sure men want to
really attract them they want a
supermodel if men can have the [ __ ] on
instagram that they're looking at
everybody wants it but i'm gonna talk
about what they would actually go for
the day for if you ask most of them like
i'm fine with the average dude you know
in terms of looks and everything else
but looks yeah women still today are
shack it up trust me
i don't see some beautiful [ __ ] being
like you can put in my push i'm like
really thank you
me
i appreciate it well you know
thank you for sponsoring this child you
know um
but uh but yeah yeah world vision ass
[ __ ] hey man hey listen i'll put flies
and booger off my face if it means i'm
getting in that pond
this was
this [ __ ] gonna pop out his
belly just again
i am 12.
with a full ass grown beard
ah get the [ __ ] out of here if you know
this pose
you know this pose
yeah i know this pose so when you're so
hungry [ __ ] gotta lift their hands
over their head just to keep it up yeah
anyways let us know what you guys think
of the car i want to rest my head
and lift my arm at the same time